you know when you're making a decision
in City Hall that really is only going
to change the city 5 10 15 years down
the line you got to be thinking about
what the young people want because we're
the ones that are going to be around uh
but moreover than that the the young
people
in this community that were maybe a
little bit
um
disconnected from the greater Binghamton
community in some ways I think I I think
looking back I did a lot to connect
young people into the Binghamton
community and just do what we could to
bridge that Gap
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast international DJ house music
producer creative Superstar and someone
I consider a friend Conrad Taylor
welcome Conrad thank you Andrew thank
you everyone thank you thank you thank
you please stop all right so I saw a
movie called we are your friends with
Zac Efron X years ago that is or is not
house music I've never seen that film oh
really
no because it's like EDM he talks about
heart rates and he's a DJ there's uh
Emily ratajowski however you say her
name is involved
um you have to see this movie apparently
because this is like my major background
um but
how the heck does one become
an international DJ that's a that's a
great question
um
so the way that I'm doing it and there's
a lot of different paths but I'm doing
it with no labels no promoters no
producers just
a genuine desire to make people dance
um so you know we know each other from
working together on on both of your
campaigns but music has always been a
huge part of my life
and uh this past year I wanted to give
that a shop professionally so I came out
with my first track
um and people kind of loved it and then
they just hit kept hitting play play
play over and over again and then you
played it at some of the hottest clubs
in New York and everyone starts
screaming and dancing and then you come
out that's pretty much the way it went
down it wasn't quite that romantic but I
was definitely taken aback by
how many people did genuinely and enjoy
it and this is just something that I'd
worked on for a few months and tweaked
and fine-tuned so I'm no house music
connoisseur but Evelyn and I loved it
and played it over and over again and
our kids loved it uh you're something of
a musical prodigy you grew up here in
New York City you got into LaGuardia
performing arts school which is the fame
school that uh all of the celebrities
ended up going to and you you had a
choice between that school and like a
more normal school how old were you when
that went down so I was in eighth grade
and I don't know how many people know
much about the New York City High School
admissions process but so okay I'm in my
40s so everyone my age knows Fame I want
to live forever
so so that high school is LaGuardia high
school so I call it the fame school
um and to get in is very very difficult
you have to be an extraordinary
performer when you for you you got in uh
through for vocals and acting yeah yeah
so this then at this point there was a
bit of a fork in the road and where were
your parents on this
my parents were were supportive of me I
mean I I had done some acting work as a
child I was in the Metropolitan Opera
here at Lincoln Center and some
commercials
um but I was also
academically and politically oriented as
a student and as a child so like this
was the really the first moment in my
youth where I had to make wow a genuine
decision between
life paths and I ended up choosing to go
to the school shout out Bard high school
early college it's a public school on
the Lower East Side where you graduate
with an associate's degree at the end of
your four years which has been a really
cool like thing for a public school in
New York City to offer
um but that was like sort of this like I
want to focus on serious stuff serious
stuff exactly with which you know now
I've made that transition from politics
back into music but these are sort of
the two loves of my life that have that
I've danced with almost oh you can come
back again
big enough as an as an artist where I
could sort of reintegrate myself into
politics in a in a new way because I've
worked on campaigns I've been an elected
official myself oh yeah so so the story
of how you became an elected official is
so epic and fascinating where you became
the youngest elected official in the
country at the time as a college student
so you come out of high school you go to
a State University of New York
Binghamton where I had a lot of friends
who went it's the flagship State
University here in New York and you run
for City Council of Binghamton yeah I
was 18 years old and I'd I'd gotten just
Ultra involved in the community like for
a number of reasons when I got to
college I was just so excited to
be independent which I think a lot of
people experience when they first go to
college away from their Hometown yep
which is just like you just want to make
this new place your home and I was very
passionate about doing that so I I got
involved with local campaigns and
politics and volunteer activities and
you know student clubs even and stuff
like that and I was learning about all
these local issues and knocking on doors
for Canada
and this one woman who I actually got
kind of close with when knocking on
doors for this candidate was like you
should be the one
running for city council not any any of
these other career politicians you know
the same thing happened to me when I was
uh supporting some other presidential
candidates someone was like you should
be the one running for president that
actually didn't happen
no no it totally didn't happen but in
your case it did happen and then you
were like maybe I should eight naive 18
year old Connor was like yeah I I I
could do that and I and I I felt like
very genuine about it which
in some ways only like an 18 year old
young person can feel that like
genuine idealism yep you know so I did
and we ended up
um building a massive operation in
Binghamton like something that could
rival any Congressional Campaign in the
country so at this point you when you
run you're a sophomore no I was a
freshman the election was one the
election was when I was a software you
showed up I got you so okay I get it I
get it you're a freshman in college
you're like you know what I'm gonna run
for city council and then you rally a
bunch of other freshmen presumably and
say hey guys I'm gonna do this thing uh
uh now this seems frankly
extraordinarily difficult to Impossible
because uh the folks who vote in these
elections are not going to be the
college students it's going to be
Binghamton locals and there is an
incumbent I imagine yeah yes so I ended
up
beating the uh or republican council
president uh
who famously at the mayor's state of the
city two weeks before my election I
overheard him talking about how he was
gonna like Crush I'm gonna crush this
kid I remember hearing that and being
like Oh okay and he had a disparaging
nickname for you and what was that
um comrade toddler
which I thought was pretty clever uh
yeah you know and yet you still
prevailed by uh knocking on everyone in
the district's door multiple times that
was certainly one of our strategies so I
would say that when that when I
announced my candidacy if the election
had been the next day I would have lost
by like 80 percent of the vote sure I
mean I was this out of town kid yup with
no political experience
the argument against me was very strong
but no one knows who you are no one
knows who I am like what do I stand for
I mean the the list goes on but
I really spent every minute for the next
10 11 months demonstrating to the people
of my district why they could I guess
trust me to do a good job including that
summer I assume yeah of course yeah
absolutely
um so yeah I walked I I walked around
and knocked on every single door in my
district at least three times I had a
hundred plus volunteers working on my
campaign I had a campaign staff you know
we were raising money we treated this
with the with the seriousness it
deserves and how many doors were in the
district
nine thousand
we're talking about 27 000 door knocks
in the space of 11 months yeah I mean
not all of those were registered voters
I would have to find the numbers but it
was a lot of doors for sure
look at it and said I'm Gonna Knock on
these doors uh and when people saw you
the second or third time they must have
been like holy crap yeah I mean I was
having tea and coffee and like people's
kitchens and living rooms and
really like diving deep about
you know not just like political issues
but also like their lives and like what
I mean I I like I I look at politicians
now
and I mean it's it's one of the reasons
that I was so enamored with you
as a as a candidate for president it's
like it's so hard when you've been in
that position to like look at someone
and be like are you genuine like
are you real like
especially now where I feel like I'm
more jaded than I have been about
politics and politicians in general
um but yeah I mean I really experienced
what it was like to to sit with someone
and then to actually eventually get into
a position where you can do something to
change their life so so you win that
race and uh were you surprised
I was not surprised by the time that we
won because I knew that we earned it and
what's that uh what was that boat town
we we beat him by 10 10 so it's 55.45
which is not bad that's that's pretty
much a landslide if you were challenging
an incumbent yeah it it felt that way
certainly
um so then you become a city council
person uh in Binghamton and you're a
college sophomore uh is that a paid
position yeah
it's
like treated as kind of
you get like a you get a healthy stipend
I would call it like it's not like here
in New York City where you get like a
hundred fancy Grand or something
that would have been crazy in 19 year
old college kid but yeah what yeah so
you win everyone's like oh my gosh you
did it uh do you get a lot of press
yeah locally certainly I mean I don't
know what I know now about
PR and National I mean I I think at the
time I could have gotten national press
for it but I just I didn't know there
was nothing
yeah but locally it was a big deal and
and they're just like a few
accomplishments that came with it that I
was like like um I think like
people at my school were very dubious at
first but ended up being quite proud
because we were able to increase young
turn out of young people by 900 in the
district and we Define that as folks 26
and under I think is how we defined it
um which is a lot but we still would
have won even without those people which
was also meaningful so it was like this
you know in a lot of college towns
although I see it as Binghamton as a
city is much much more than that but in
what people sometimes you as college
towns there's that like
of course and this was a a really
important step I think in bridging that
and from both directions because
first of all it showed that young people
have a seat at the table in our
communities regardless of where we are
um you know when you're making a
decision in City Hall that really is
only going to change the city 5 10 15
years down the line you got to be
thinking about what the young people
want because we're the ones that are
going to be around uh but moreover than
that the the young people
in this community that were maybe a
little bit
um
disconnected from the greater Binghamton
community in some ways I think I I think
looking back I did a lot to connect
young people into the Binghamton
community and just do what we could to
bridge that Gap
foreign
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
so your uh city council person
um but one of the fun projects you got
involved with is you started a a
projection Festival where they they
would light up the exteriors of
buildings with these timed
um displays I got the term wrong what
are they called yeah I didn't start it
but
um certainly like developing downtown
was a huge part of what I was focused on
on city council and the two co-founders
Josh and tice launched
um what's called the Luma projection
Arts Festival so the term that you're
looking for is projection mapping that's
it thank you so shout out to Luma
lumafestival.com it is one of the
coolest things
that you will probably ever experience
if you go to it the
um buildings come alive like you know
City Hall turns into a spaceship and so
Google Conrad Taylor music and then
Google projection mapping right right so
there are a couple things we got some
action items that will wow you and you
shared some stories with me about being
on city council that there was a there
was one where uh a local reporter used
to show up and then they stopped showing
up and then all of a sudden things went
uh were a little bit less buttoned up
after the the local press stopped yeah
appearing at these meetings well
on the presidential campaign and on the
Merrell campaign you spoke a lot about
the importance of local journalism and
independent journalism and it was one of
the things that Germany back on the
presidential because you know
politicians don't often talk about this
topic and and the reason for that is
because
I experienced it you know I was
um the youngest
person on city council by far but I was
also for a lot of the time the only
Democrat and it just created a lot of
scenarios where
um
sometimes I felt like just stuff wasn't
getting done on the council and like you
were just saying when there was a
reporter there at least one
the meeting was an entirely different
meeting
like
no one here watches their City Council
meetings on TV like their Spectrum TV or
no one watches it online no one
goes you know uh but if there's someone
reporting on it then
people in the in the community have a
sometimes a genuine idea of what's
happening or at least if you were one of
the members you'd be much more buttoned
up he was like oh [__] my my stuff could
get recorded exactly so I felt like
whenever
a reporter was there
just more would get done and we'd have
better like conversations about helping
people in our community and it the the
the the
difference was drastic and it just it it
shows me just how important political
accountability is and despite the
experiences that we have had with
certain journalists and certain outlets
and I mean you know well I find local
news to be less ideological more up the
middle you know I mean right you can't
really I mean the the void gets filled
unfortunately with cable news and
nationalized uh ideological uh squabbles
uh and Facebook feeds and the rest of it
um so you know I mean as like you you
said I mean we're connected on this but
you were one of the people that let me
know it's like hey it's not made up I
mean this [__] is exactly real life it's
so real it's so real and I mean like
kudos to the
journalists and stations in America that
prioritize their local councils and
governments because I think it makes a
huge difference in what actually gets
done for taxpayers and for voters well
kudos to them if they're still doing it
because I think that the number is that
uh I think something like
um 60 000 journalists lost their job
over the last several years yeah
um so you're this young Rising Superstar
and the Democratic party
um you get to introduce Bernie at a
rally Upstate right yeah that was
awesome yeah that was sick go Bernie
yeah I mean that like you know I was a
burner in 16 before I ran
um at least I you know I mean I get the
text to prove it
we all do
um so so you have a choice to make it a
certain point because your term is up
but you could run again you could run
for State uh State Rep uh seat and then
you decide to make something of a
dramatic shift and you show up
um in Iowa to work on the Andrew Yang
campaign like what what was the next
step after City Council on how close
were you to running for for a
legislative seat yeah yeah there were a
lot of people pressuring me to do
different things and make different
decisions running for mayor oh [__] you
could have run for mayor
for congress even yeah why not and and
this is all stuff that I was considering
um
why did I make the decision that I did
there's two that's not even the fact
that I'm awesome
that's number one number two and three
well actually that's part of the number
that's part of one of them so the first
thing is that
I got into politics to stop the endemic
of career politics that was part of my
message
I felt like a hypocrite becoming a
career politician I really did
and I actually think career politics is
very dangerous I think that
um anything that is a career
has inherent self-interest baked into it
you know one thing I don't like that I
have a feeling you don't like and most
Americans don't like is that that
whenever someone leaves office as like a
Feeding Frenzy of officials the level
below them it's my turn yeah it's
lighter it's my turn everyone's like a
grumpy like oh whose turn is it is it
their turn is it is it your turn and it
just seems like such nonsense it's like
so you have like a bizarre career ladder
trajectory and and and that's how we
decide who the heck should be I mean you
know you can see this at every level
unfortunately absolutely
um so I didn't really want to be a part
of that uh
and yeah I feel like public service just
can't have that inherent
selfishness that is attached to a career
and and that doesn't mean that there
aren't incredible public servants who
are career politicians who are doing it
for the right reasons but part of
building a career is making decisions
about your career and climbing the
ladder and I just didn't want to do that
because I wanted to stay
in politics for the right reasons if
that makes sense makes sense to me so I
had some time to make some genuine
Reflections about what was currently
motivating me politically because I knew
I didn't want to leave politics at the
time it was all that I really thought
about
um and for me that was defeating Donald
Trump I was
I saw even in local Politics the
drastic change
in how certain conservatives operated
post Trump like I think like a lot of
casually racist remarks were a lot more
common
um
sort of carelessness about
fact was a lot more common yeah he had a
profound cultural impact on people say
he normalized things that previously
would not have been in the bounds a
hundred percent so I was seeing this
local impact on the Trump era but of
course just nationally it was
man I was like Trump's a giant red flag
what the heck we gonna do uh the economy
is transforming like you know there are
only a few things I can see that might
fix it I'm going to run for for
president and try and yeah and you know
I was I was I always said Trump was not
the disease he's a symptom of a disease
that's getting worse which by the way is
still true 100
um and and I mean honestly like
this goes back to you being awesome
thanks man I did think that you were the
antidote I genuinely did
I was on council at this time
and I was I'm very proud of a lot of
things that I got done but I'm also very
disappointed about a lot of things that
I didn't and part of why those things
maybe didn't come to fruition was my
inability to
connect with
more conservative mind of people
interesting and
convince them essentially
and I saw this divide just getting
greater and greater in our country I
knew that I was not special and feeling
this way and I saw you as literally one
of the only people that I could [__]
do it well and Binghamton so people know
Upstate New York is a fairly reddish
area you said that you were one of the
only Democrats on Council yeah it's
pretty split at this time I think I like
the there was a bit of a red wave in
Binghamton
um that I was able to fight against the
the city itself is pretty split even
leans blue sometimes during purplish
well it's in college town too College
tend to be tend to be bluish but then
generally speaking Upstate New York is
absolutely yeah red and would be quite
trumpy yeah absolutely yeah it went for
Trump uh
uh I think actually I think Upstate New
York one person so you would be living
The Divide in a way that most of us
would were not and I I was trying to uh
Heal The Divide exactly yeah so I was
like I'm gonna fight against Trump and
I'm gonna do that by helping Andre Ang
win
thank you
if you know me you know that I think
that our data should be ours and that
big Tech right now is running roughshod
on our autonomy our agency our privacy
for sure one way to help turn the tables
on big Tech is to use expressvpn like I
do when I surf the web it keeps you
private by piping you in to another IP
address it's what big companies use it
was rated the number one VPN that's
virtual private Network by CNET wired
and more let's take it back from Big
Tech Stop handing over your personal
data to the quasi-monopolies that mine
our activity and sell our info for their
profit not ours protect yourself with a
VPN I trust to keep me and mine safe
online visit expressvpn.com Yang that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com to get three extra
months free
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
so how the heck do you get a job on my
campaign because I will say for my uh
from my vantage point I'm just like you
know campaigning and where do we meet
New Hampshire Iowa we met in Iowa
and then it's like hey this is Conrad
he's on the advanced team he's gonna be
helping you out and I was like Conrad eh
and then someone had given me a couple
of your uh stats ahead of time being
like Jesus studies you know the youngest
elected official in the in the uh
country
um you know uh uh he's can do with the
rest of it I was like I'm sure I'll like
him and then I met you and
um did like you
um but I I remember that I started to
interrupt you I remember that the first
time that I met you you were and you did
this a lot you were like I was like
dropping you off at your hotel room
because like you don't know where in the
world you are you're like here this is
where you're sleeping tonight yeah and
then you're like nice to meet you would
you like a picture with me and I was
like sure well because I don't know if
I'm going to see you again it was like
it was it was just such a funny little
anecdote about how crazy things were for
you during that time where yeah no thank
you man I was trying to be considerate I
don't know when who yeah I was like wow
I can't believe he asked me that
um and and I think a lot of people took
note you were always uh
trying to make sure that the people that
work for you felt appreciated well I
felt shitty that I didn't know the team
members better because when I ran an
organization or a company I made in my
business to know people well but when
you're a presidential candidate you're
like you said it's like get in this
vehicle
man he's gonna take you here and I'm
like who's this could be a volunteer
could be an advanced staff yeah it could
be an Uber driver I don't [__] know
um so
uh so how easy or hard was it to get
that job it was a presidential campaign
so it certainly wasn't easy
um
but for me
I think I had an interesting resume yeah
and then I knew somebody that worked on
the campaign who was able to vouch for
me as well oh really who was that that
was Annie oh dope yeah yeah I don't know
if you're if you remember her but uh all
right so you show up in iom what month
is that
that was in November wow so that's
November 2019 and so you have like the
the three months that were the most high
energy and hectic yeah and you didn't
just hang out in Iowa because you
Advanced us all over the place so you
land in Iowa and then we went all over
New Hampshire Washington California and
oh there was a presidential debate in
December yeah yeah is your staff that
thing too yeah for a little bit
um South Carolina I like to think that
when I joined I mean this like Shelby
shout out to Shelby and Ethan or
um
for being incredible but I do like to
think that when I join we were able to
elevate like the level of on-the-ground
events
you know when I showed up it just
leveled up the whole operation I like to
think that I helped well I will say
Conrad is excellent
um at making things uh better and more
professional in terms of staging and
whatnot I mean like your attention to
detail is very very high energy level
super high and what people don't know is
that advanced staff need to be freaking
indefatigable machines or Warriors like
you know like I mean my hours are bad
and like you're like doing stuff
beforehand like
you end up in the wrong City so or or I
go to a place for speaking and there's
like a stage and a backdrop and people
and a photo op and the rest of it uh and
you know and then I leave and then
someone's like wrapping all that stuff
up and sometimes they're like taking the
same side and like trying to get ahead
yeah we got to beat the bus gotta be the
bus I got a few speeding tickets on that
campaign but um but but what a journey
those few months were between November
and uh February oh my God yeah I mean
what what are your uh strongest or
Fondest Memories there's so many
um I was really
proud of so we we qualified for that
December California debate in California
and you crushed that you crushed that
debate it must have been one of your
best if not your best I think it was my
best yeah I think so too and I think
there was a moment when we were like
okay
okay you know and and and and that was
certainly around then and then we went
into Iowa feeling maybe better than
we've ever felt and then you like
scored really well in like nine poles
and then but in a week and the four
that you didn't score that well in were
the ones that like qualif would have
qualified you for the January debate in
Iowa so you were like one pole short we
didn't qualify for the i o debate that
was a big sting for us and for our
momentum that we were building we had
just gotten a great fundraising quarter
it was just it was just not what we
deserved I think and not what the Yang
gang deserved honestly to not qualify
for that debate
because it wasn't indicative of the
momentum we were building out yeah yeah
we were having a good run we were having
a good run and then immediately
afterwards a poll came out with me
precisely at that yeah exactly and then
so we were you know an iohq thinking
what are we gonna do to
[Music]
demonstrate that this isn't indicative
of that and that we can that we're you
know we're one of the big players which
we were
um so basically
it was you know I had the idea
essentially to do a like our
massive rally biggest rally we've ever
done the night before the debate when
all of the reporters were already in
town National reporters on your birthday
we would make it like a our basically
our biggest event yet in Iowa
hopefully as many reporters as possible
and you know that that's the plan that
we ended up executing
um and you know it was just it was my
event that I built and it was it was
definitely one of the proudest moments
for me on the presidential campaign
because I felt like that event just went
so well we had like a thousand people
there I remember that night yeah I
remember uh the happy birthday
um song which I appreciated
uh uh I just celebrated Yang week with
some
um folks online and and this was when
people from all over the country
descended on Iowa their campaign and wow
did that bring back some memories I mean
that that was a magic yeah that was a
very special time for all of us yeah it
really felt that way
and that entrepreneurial spirit that
you had and then everyone else who
supported you had
lives on now it lives on with my
decision now to like do music and uh
it's I mean it's one reason why you are
such like a an energizing invigorating
presence and DJ by the way can like you
know make the people move and whatnot
um but you're the sort of person that
formed the core of the Yang gang really
is like people who just think that good
things are possible and it did feel like
that in Iowa I remember that vividly
like where we went there's just so much
energy around us uh we I mean we spent
whatever it was you know
um like seven eight million dollars on
TV ads just in Iowa so yeah turn on the
TV and there was uh there was a lot of
this guy
uh and falling short in Iowa was was uh
really hard
um I spoke at one of the events that
night and uh I was thinking you go in
because like there are all these signs
for the other candidates and then there
was like the Yang pocket but it was a
pocket it wasn't like yeah
um you know it wasn't a majority by by
any means
so I was like oh this is indicative I
know it's a pretty big site so I was
like this isn't going to be an anomaly
you know I'm a married guy so it's like
the odds of that were pretty low
[Laughter]
uh and and so you know that that was a
tough tough night and then we
immediately had to go to New Hampshire
which you were a part of as well yeah
yeah we had a we were like in the
process of losing Iowa and that was also
a crazy night because the ballots
weren't being yeah how do you feel about
the fact that the Dems are kicking Iowa
to the curb
as someone who was very witness to the
nonsense that was the 2019 or 2020 Iowa
caucus I mean I get it you know I mean I
I feel bad for Iowa and Iowans uh you
know it was a quintessential purple
State 12 years ago Obama won it in the
general and then now it's Republican
plus nine
um you know and and the Democratic party
is actually giving up on it saying like
you're too rural too white too
Midwestern we're out uh and and I think
it's just a terrible message uh it makes
me sad as someone who spent a lot of
time in Iowa and oh by the way the same
Dynamics playing out in Ohio even which
used to be quintessential purple and is
now plus eight or nine red and um Tim
Ryan I thought ran a great campaign and
he still loses by whatever it was seven
points to you know a candidate who in my
opinion was not good at all no in the
form of JD Vance I mean that dude you
know and that dude only got 32 percent
of the Republican primaries so it just
goes to show you like weak Republican
strong Democrat they they still lose the
general by seven or so absolutely yeah
so so the national debaconic party's
going to be like well we'll just trade
Ohio and Iowa in for uh Arizona and
um Nevada or Virginia or something and
called a day meanwhile all the Dems of
Iowa who you and I spent all his time
with and Ohio will be like what the heck
happened to us yeah you're right about
that yeah
foreign
I've always been a mattress guy it's one
reason I'm so thrilled that this podcast
is sponsored by Helix sleep Helix sleep
is the future of mattresses you take the
Helix sleep quiz at their website and
get your perfect mattress fit in under
two minutes it takes a little longer for
them to get that to your door but when
they send it to your door you get a
hundred night free trial I know it's
crazy that's over three months and then
over a 10-year warranty to try out your
new Helix mattress it's become the go-to
mattress for my kids in the house and
they have a few mattresses to choose
from but they just always seem to find
this one you don't need to take my kids
word for it it's also the number one
mattress pick by wired GQ imagine that
job just trying out mattresses for
magazines but it's number one and it's
number one for a reason Helix is
offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com yang
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now
[Music]
foreign
so then I drop out in New Hampshire it's
a very emotional time uh and then fly to
Nevada to thank people I just found out
the other night when I was reminiscing
with folks that there were people that
were in New Hampshire that um wanted to
see me then I like didn't come out for
because I didn't know they were there I
mean I was like in like you know I'd
addressed people and I was in the back
like you know trying to figure things
out
um so that made me feel like oh like you
know I missed that or let's let some
people down
um but then
you and I campaign down in Georgia later
that year for
um Senators Warnock and awesome and made
cash relief reality before that made
cash relief a reality like we did all
the stuff in in 2020 which was a weird
um time and then uh you become one of
the key people on the mayoral campaign
which makes sense because as you can
tell Conrad's a New Yorker and so he's
like we're gonna do this uh and it went
great yeah Conrad elevated our
operations there too no um so that that
was
um that was a tough time in New York it
was a tough race yeah uh you know this
just a lot of struggling humans uh a lot
of uh and we encountered many and I I
felt the worst for you because
um I think
because you know Conrad literally got
physically accosted uh multiple times
that I can remember
uh and I felt so bad so like when things
were going
um poorly in a particular event or
gathering Conrad was a person who would
essentially have to like intercede
um to to you know like help or whatnot
and so you know I'm not so bad for you
Manny it's like it's like you know it's
like as you remember at that time on the
Staten Island Ferry where like the the
guy attacked the photograph of course
yeah so that that was one of those
things
that was one of the times where I was
the intervener and in some ways that's
even more comfortable for me than being
like the guy who their their people are
trying to protect and then someone else
intervening on my behalf like I'm not
I'm not much of a bodyguard type I don't
know if you can tell he's a lover not a
fighter he's an artist uh so
um but that Staten Island Ferry when
like that that like that so in that case
I just noticed like a guy is freaking
assaulting someone so I jump out of my
seat and go holy cow and intervene and
then happily the guy recognized me and
then stands down yeah chills out that
was but but you know that that guy ended
up
um uh hospitalizing someone else yeah
like uh two or three weeks later I think
it was an Asian American too it was an
elderly Sri Lankan man yeah made me feel
terrible I mean I like obviously we
weren't people who could decide that
whether you're gonna arrest the guy
based on you know we brought the police
in and then they you know no we we saw
we saw some Darkness during those few
months it was a it was a tough time for
New Yorkers especially when we got into
the race I mean it was the Deep of
winter it was when omnicron Omicron was
like at its height
at the beginning of 2021
and I was really proud of of the
like lightness and
hope that we brought to that race at the
time you know the the economic message
the like for a while we were the only
people actually going out there and like
meeting people that's true it was a
virtual school you got me kind of but
um but uh it was it was worth it because
you know we we got to actually connect
and inspire a little bit we got more
individual uh donations than any candy
in the history of New York City yeah and
so there were a lot of people that were
excited uh didn't go our way and so then
when we came off of that
um you know you went to unwind
um and I went to unwind honestly so in
my case you read a book but fine so I'll
tell you this story actually I don't
know how much of this you knew in the
Maryland so
uh so I finished the book at the very
end of 2020 right and then conclude it's
like oh the two-party system not working
so I should do something about that
um but then no talk about that uh until
after the mayoral and so then the book
comes out and I'm then touring
nationally and doing but thank you for
everyone who came to the book tour like
loved meeting people and
um and I will say to you and I like that
if I hadn't had that book launch and
book tour scheduled for uh the fall I'm
not sure if I would have like gotten
back out there in that time frame
because after the mayoral I was like I
need a freaking vacation yeah you didn't
really get much of it I feel like yeah I
I didn't because of the way the timeline
worked like I came off the mayoral and
then I had called my publisher and they
were like we want to publish this book
as soon as possible and I was like what
the heck does that mean in terms of date
they were like October 5th and I said
all right I can be ready October 5th and
then when October 5th came around did I
feel
you know it's like not particularly but
you know just like uh you know get back
on the horse
now for me it went in a different
direction and I had the luxury to be
able to go a different direction you
know I didn't have
the weight of a entire nation on my
shoulders but
um
yeah I I reconnected I mean we talked
about this at the beginning of my
podcast which is like my story is a bit
of a a story of
you know politics and public service but
also of music and the Arts and I kind of
reconnected with that side of myself and
and especially my love for electronic
music and really got in I mean I'm I'm a
German American so I have German
citizenship
I speak the language spelled spend some
time in Germany and in Spain and the
house music capital of the world Berlin
baby
techno I think they would probably
the Techno music capital of the world
that that yeah dudes um
it is actually house and Technology are
from the US like from Detroit and
Chicago which is really cool
um shout out Detroit I know that which
is sick shout out to Troy uh but yeah so
I reconnected with that released my
first song
um started getting offers to DJ some
places yes I have been incredibly
fortunate to to DJ some of the coolest
spots here in New York City and build a
bit of a following and
I mean
I think of like my happiest moments of
2022 they are all
behind the decks creating
just an experience for people on the
dance floor it just brings me so much
happiness and joy to be able to do that
it's almost like my new Public Service
in a lot of ways well you can see it man
I mean I've been there personally and
I've also seen the videos and you are so
pumped to get other People Pumped it's
really beautiful it's like it's so
cathartic for me actually uh and I mean
I'm I only want to grow that from here I
I have a real vision for
like just a revolution
Revolution on the dance floor
um but what I mean by that is like
I think a lot of people when they think
about going out to the club or something
similar
they think of
High drink prices I think of standing in
line they think of music maybe that they
don't really want to listen to I mean
you can get darker with it too and you
can think of like being inappropriately
touched or you can think of being unsafe
having your drink spiked you know this
is
um could be much worse these thoughts if
you're if you're someone who identifies
as a woman
so I think that
there is room for a revolution here
about like creating a much safer much
more inclusive dance floor where you
just like and you see this a lot more in
Europe
um where you just go to
to Vibe and be and have a meditative
almost experience a cathartic experience
to reconnect with yourself to build
community like right now a lot of DJs
that you see come out of a
what kind of come out of like Greek
culture in the US which is not like
Greek as in Greece Greek as in
fraternities and sororities
and I know some awesome awesome DJs that
come out of this like Greek to DJ
pipeline but
you know and and feel free it's not the
vibe that you just described it's not
the vibe that I just described and it's
not just not that Vibe it's actually in
a lot of circumstances
like a a
dangerous Vibe and what I mean by that
is like fraternities and sororities and
I think this might piss a lot of people
off right now but they create
oftentimes really really unsafe spaces
to party in I just saw a documentary to
this effect and I I know what you're
talking about I think most people do
yeah it upholds like this culture of
rape misogyny
that actually goes to a lot of our
American systems uh this podcast snapped
which my sister makes because she has
had some really dark experiences in the
space talks about this a lot more
um but like Congress is majority
returning sorority and again I know so
many amazing people that come from the
space but the culture that is being
created is not once of not one of
safeness inclusivity
fun in a way that is is there a term for
this more positive version of uh EDM
Gathering
I can't think of I can't because you
should coin this term and what you just
described reminds me of Howard Schultz
going to I believe Italy and seeing this
little cafe and being like oh they do
coffee in a more elevated way and then
he comes back and popularize it via
Starbucks I feel like you you had like a
different type of experience you're like
oh I should popularize this in other
places yeah absolutely and and I I also
don't want to take away from
um
like this already is a thing you know
you have incredible plate spaces in New
York City alone that are mostly in
Brooklyn that embody this
same kind of atmosphere and vision
um like house music comes out of
you know Detroit and Chicago which is
where this started this kind of feeling
but with that being said I think we have
to
push back in that direction
and with you know with a lot more
learned well your music is very very
feel good uh everything I've heard of
yours it has like this
jubilance
um that I I feel like would lead people
in a positive direction yeah yeah thank
you um yeah and I've got a lot more
coming out this year with that same uh
feeling in mind just like you know
feeling the beat and feeling good and uh
yeah yeah and so you know follow me on
Spotify Conrad Taylor follow Conrad
Taylor on Spotify check out a couple of
his songs just now I pretty much
guarantee that you will at least be
tapping your feet or doing something
physical don't put a smile on your face
uh and
um
you you're
you know both very Advanced and also
just getting started it's really a joy
for me to see and most people wouldn't
have the courage to do pretty much half
the things you just described that
you've already done by The Ripe old age
of 26. I mean when I have people young
people ask me about how to get involved
in various ways
uh I don't say hey run for office
because that seems like a bridge too far
though you know apparently not I mean do
it um but what I do say is like find a
campaign you're excited about and go and
contribute and then if you're good
you'll get a lot of responsibility
because you and I both know you know
like good people are hard to find
totally
so yeah but you're good you'll get stuff
uh and you wound up with an uh you know
incredible amount of responsibility
because you're excellent
um and and so I see in you someone who
actually took the advice that I get uh
give the young people sometimes
um but and but now you're applying your
passions in this new direction that uh
that speaks to who you are and will uh
give people also uh the you know the the
same sense of optimism and joy that you
want them to feel it's it's really
inspirational thank you yeah I hope so I
hope so and I I hope
to continue growing with that exact
philosophy in mind
um
you know it it it's impossible to not be
in this position where you're like just
getting started as an artist and seeing
some small levels of success like you're
visions of grandeur or large maybe
they're delusions of grandeur but I
certainly
just not at all man I mean you're you're
a talented hard-working person so if you
want to be part of this journey
um I would love that follow me on
Instagram
conrad.taylor same thing on Tick Tock
Twitter
uh Spotify is just Conrad Taylor I've
got big things coming and I would love
for everyone here to be a part of it
we'd love to be a part of it brother and
I can't wait to keep track of your
journey Conrad you're on your way thanks
man
thanks